you guys ever watched the Boogie Nights
oh yeah you're in Boogie Nights dude so
at the end yeah at the end of booking
yeah dude it's weird no when I first
first moved to LA is like in the 90s
right like they there was a thing on
Craigslist same [__] and at the end of
Boogie Nights it's when they need him to
take out his dick and it's me that's my
dick that's my big old [__] fat
[__] dude I knew it man I
perfect huge penis in my life
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys
hey this I thought would be a really
funny thing okay what are some
movies music videos TV shows or other
media
where you can be spotted and not a lot
of people know that
like other Industries music video I was
in that music video I told you guys
about oh yeah which one with what the
[__] is his name Riff Raff Riff Raff yes
oh were you wearing glasses in the
office yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm in the
office what was the name of that song
again I don't remember
but I should and Steve was a skinny boy
in that I was a real skinny woman oh
it's the illest one with Alice that's
the one yeah wow okay so look at the
illest with Far East Movement and I hung
out with those guys all day they're
really cool Riff Raff's a really cool
dude really nice I heard he is really a
really nice fella Steve is like the
office guy yeah we watched it me and my
buddy Peter Gilroy we were both in that
one together he's like my bud
I feel like if I was at a rodeo I don't
think people will recognize me like that
is all right no we so for us we were in
um hey look at this so in case you
haven't seen it whoa it follows it out
of rodeo people right is that what
you're asking no like if you're already
in something that people don't wow dude
what year is this I think I was like 26
or something good it's so young dude 27.
Kevin Nash
um me and Bart are in uh key and peel oh
which one what
um we're in the audience and then
this is good so like people were
watching they're like we saw you on Key
and Peele and then it's like we're like
you know when they cut to people and
they're laughing yeah we're out of live
taping yeah we watched because
um our um writing teacher is there is is
there sketch writer so then he invited
us and we're just right that's pretty
cool yeah right in the front row we're
just cracking up and then they used our
footage of us laughing I got to write
with them one time it was really fun oh
that's cool those guys are way funnier
in person than what because you're not
like it's like hard to contain like like
funny sometimes kind of like it's hard
to contain a sound like how they say
Jennifer Hudson is just way crazier live
than like in our studio recording like
their improv skills are so insane it's
hard to like get in a nice TV commercial
type format but they're like crazy I
didn't think they were funny in person
really no they were great
no we actually talked about fantasy
football the whole time like because
we're but we're we're all into NFL [__]
so we were just like riffing on that
[__] all day it was fun but but I used
to do this show called Equals Three with
Ray Liam Johnson he was like the top two
birthday yeah and then he came they came
through and they were [__] dope I
love those guys yeah that's cool you
want to see something funny you know
that song Papa Roach uh it's uh
yeah it doesn't happen but the song
Scars how does that go again I remember
those remind us what the past is real I
remember that so this is the music video
for that and you can see me in it where
I'm just a this is my first ever like
whatever's job is an extra and that's me
in the back wait what the [__] I already
missed you where'd you go is that you
right there it pops up every now and
then but
that's one of them let me see the when
she like disses him I like steal the
freaking scene for a second
what were you what was your role nothing
I was just an extra this is the first
time it's ever on set that's me
[Music]
this is before before Quest or anything
yeah yeah I was like this is like it's
like 2001
how did you do that like you wanted to
get into entertainment I just went on
Craigslist and then there was a thing
for a music video and I just submitted
my photo yeah just mad early days yeah
dude if you watch um you guys ever
watched the Boogie Nights oh yeah you're
Boogie Nights dude so at the end yeah at
the end of books yeah dude it's weird
what no when I first first moved to LA
is like in the 90s right like they there
was a thing on Craigslist same [__] and
at the end of Boogie Nights it's when
they need him to take out his dick and
it's me that's my dick that's my big old
[__] fat [__] dude I knew it man
see the more perfect huge penis in my
life if you were the plumper for that
scene thank you thank you no no like
that movie's so old I was like like
[__] 10 years old
and I'm a grower too so it's different
no my um I was in the movie um we talked
about all the time um with old Kev Hart
wedding ringer yeah old Kev Hart and
actually Josh gadd is a [__] nice
fella I got to hang out with him yeah
while we were both in the makeup trailer
he was in there he was just like asking
me questions about [__] and being just a
polyper I heard he's a cool guy very
cool guy there's um I'm in the end of uh
Fat Albert the movie oh where are you in
that sure I'm literally just a guy sang
by a tree oh for no reason we had this
charity thing with um how did you get
that kick because churches do Charities
where uh you all sign up as extras and
you just give the money to the the
church or the charity oh cool yeah the
last thing I did was fabulous Filipino
Bros hey that just came out that was fun
last thing you did it's hard to
recognize Joe in that movie it's stupid
but it's a lot of fans that didn't know
would they watch it they're like I can't
believe you're in this thing yeah but uh
it's not like an extra thing so I guess
it's more in your face that's true it is
hard to miss it where did you get any
footage of you as an audience member at
Comics Unleashed
I never saw anything you know you know
what one thing that I did
um that sometimes people bring up and
I'm like I cannot believe you saw me
there is I was on there was Wayne Brady
to this [__] game show
and again early days right like I was
invited there with my girlfriend at the
time and we're both in the audience and
like we randomly answered the question
but we got it completely wrong and
that's it like you just see us for a
second it's like wrong thank you Steve
and you know and it was like weird I
couldn't believe that that you were the
mango for Annoying Orange oh yeah how
the hell is that a thing I'm about to
danebo's been my buddy for years I love
danebo um he's The Annoying Orange do
you guys know Annoying Orange yeah the
with the mouth yeah he's the mango I'm
the mango that was one of the biggest
channels in OG YouTube yeah and I didn't
understand it but I didn't realize like
YouTube the biggest audience was like
12. so my my no idea my very close
friend to this day Aaron Massey is that
he he's Mr Fix It On YouTube if you
watch YouTube but he um he is the
producer of that show so then oh I got
like I met I mean in when you're in the
tube land like everyone kind of meets
each other but then I got in there that
way okay and then they were just like
come to your voices this guy named Bob
Jens got me and he was like a legend
over there that's so funny that that's
you man yeah it's it dude I did so much
[__] back then we're just like you just
don't know you're just going to do stuff
and then yeah you don't realize it and
see where it ends up yeah yeah yeah are
you in any weird [__] like small [__]
when you were starting out the people
don't recognize you for no I didn't
really do a lot of commercial stuff uh
like because you weren't going to
auditions for a while I remember no I
wasn't you weren't I've only done two
auditions of my life one of them I was
on shrooms that's the only ones you did
have you ever danced for another group
um and then you could point it out like
at the sub in for some books I know that
happens sometimes right with like dance
crews it was like oh [__] this guy can't
make it so we'll have this guy sub in
not for like commercial work that wasn't
like kinja's represented or something
like that oh okay like I'm not really
even early days
um
not really out because I wasn't
submitting for auditions or cast you
know doing casting stuff or anything
like that I was like I see not
successful
you never did like a news interview what
you were talking about yeah man went
boom and I was ready like like I was uh
I was in a uh uh Asian campaign for a
McDonald's commercial that was only on
Asian channels so like regular people in
America probably have no idea that I'm
in this Kennedy pulled up yeah you could
literally look like look up Kendra's
McDonald's is that when they invited all
the Asian YouTubers and [__] no this is
literally like a all-day breakfast where
it's like girl we're sleepwalking and we
Sleepwalk our way into [__]
McDonald's uh that's pretty funny
oh what McDonald's oh there's Anthony
this is like a full-on Asian campaign
like people like why does it look like
you guys are in the back of a Ralphs
it's it's at a it's it's literally for
Asian channels so like all my like
aunties and uncles and random [__] would
hit me up and be like you're in the
McDonald's commercial but like nobody
else would would see this because they
saw you on channel 18 yeah and gently
one of the funniest things I heard about
Anthony recently was from um my buddy
Chad Ventures actually
um and he yeah he's he's on the patreon
he's on the crypto corner and he was
saying that he was like you know what's
so funny is that when I watch Anthony
I'm like wow there's this like super
accomplished guy like world classic
worldwide he's known for dance and he
spends all day just getting [__]
roasted on JK news
what
these all survive longer without a
whooping cough
hey good point my lung capacity isn't
very good it's it's a real thing Anthony
it's actually not fake it's real people
on the organ Trail died of it
it is true that I don't know why I come
here
um but other than that the only other
like music videos I was doing were like
uh like the Jackson one of these videos
and stuff oh right right we already
that's me yeah but that's like now yeah
you can't hide that yeah that Asian
cheeky eye that asses me I was in a
veterans commercial I don't know if you
could go oh really yeah write a Bart
Quan veterans commercial or something
this is old old old old
how old is it I don't know it might be
somewhere
um well you didn't type commercial
though oh veterans commercial yeah
I'm gonna take a photo with Steve later
just match her up yeah all right we're
gonna make a flyer I don't think I can
find people want us to box what
I saw that it was on the just kidding
news Discord there's a lot going on in
that dish on patreon yeah you guys gotta
get on that patreon Discord though but
I'm telling you maybe we'll maybe we
will we will maybe we'll I don't know I
don't I don't think it's coming up
do you remember any other like was there
a theme Bart would you train me or would
you trade Anthony
I would train both of you and then I'll
tell both of you guys each other's
weaknesses different [__] okay different
[__] okay okay
interesting yeah I'm pulling out a box
like a a baseball that my my little
brother sent overseas to me oh in the
commercial the commercial yeah
do you know is there any other keywords
I don't know this is so old
I remember at that time though I think
Jake it might have been like 2008 or 9
or 10. it was super early on JK and I
would get like random comments like yeah
I saw you in the commercial oh dang it I
was all cool
yeah I would only do like weird like
random Youtube stuff that like remember
when like Nigahiga and then they did
like they made a fake K-pop group oh
yeah
yeah that was in that music video is
like uh whatever I remember that but
that was like YouTube stuff
that era was fun it was honestly it felt
like anything could go and then it would
[__] just get viral as [__] too yeah
OG YouTube and everyone was just trying
to create like they were trying to
create music videos sketches like some
kind of content
um and I like traveling and doing all
these things and then you see all your
like peers there that was so far that's
the best part yeah you're like oh and
you're like almost and you meet up in
like different countries yeah and you
see the more I was also there then if
you look up the uh the um Wolverine
trailer I'm in that what are you real
real yeah it might be a parody trailer
but I mean uh for [__] sakes it's the
JK one type JK oh it's stupid Google JK
but yeah I don't know dude it's the best
one though right for sure this is when
I'm getting ready to leave the party
it's when everyone's pulling up old
YouTube videos that they did I'm like
yeah I'm getting ready
what was the video where you and
Lawrence reaching for the cabinets this
is one more reason for the cab is the
cookie jar on top yeah I don't know wow
you look so young here and cool Soo
Young have some pizza that's him dad you
pulled it up I didn't know when did you
come to JK
dude this dude he's been here forever
like
2012 13. that's so [__] cool
audio right now please stop it it's
pretty good actually it's probably
better yeah because the joke's not there
at all yeah there's no joke it's just
awkward it's just what the [__]
happening during that time when you guys
were doing awesome like gigs and just
like doing all that stuff
were you like were you thinking about
being a actor or going into film or
anything
When what when you were like doing
auditions doing background work all that
stuff I didn't know anything I was just
doing whatever I had no clue about how
anything worked I just thought because
back then there was no YouTuber like no
one there you made YouTube videos but
that word wasn't really there no yeah it
wasn't at all and it was it was a
survival thing it was like Hey we're all
just doing this [__] you want to be in
my [__] yeah I do it's like yeah
nobody's paying anybody duh bro we're
just all gonna be it was also wild back
then I remember being on that on that
Papa Roach [__] that was the first time
I had been anywhere with cameras and
lights and anything and I was just like
this is so cool and then at one point
the uh one of the director guys or one
of the producers was like hey any girls
here any two girls want to make out for
the for the shot and then um they were
all like the guys were like all laughing
like the producer guys and then these
two girls were like okay I guess we'll
do it and then so they they did a a cut
where they're like all right well we'll
just do this we'll just shoot this by
itself and then girls are like making
out like on the side it's like a little
side shot of the party and then it
didn't even make the cut so it was
further no and I feel like they never
were even shooting it they were just
like being like nasty like what the hell
yeah it's like wild
my first extra work ever was actually in
high school
I think I was like 15 or maybe 16. one
of my friends was like Hey so like I do
extra work on the side do you want to
just come and like I had no plans of
ever getting into like entertainment or
whatever or anything but then you know
like when you're when you're at that age
it's like if someone's gonna do
something fun like hey I know if this a
broken down Mall you want to go inside
we'll go skateboard inside everyone just
goes yeah yeah yeah yeah oh [__] yeah
I'm like where is it she's like I'll
just go to Lancaster or whatever I'm
okay cool so we go and it was a night I
remember it being a night scene and then
seeing like uh you we signed up and you
just signed this form that you're going
to be an extra whatever and then you
would go to this wardrobe lady and then
they were just passing out like random
dress shirts and stuff because it was a
club scene yeah so everyone just got
like a shirt and then we they packed all
of us into this room and then uh they
passed out fake cigarettes for everyone
to smoke because they needed the room to
be all Smoky because those are fun yeah
it was like and then we didn't finish
until like 5 a.m and I'm like this is
[__] boring
what's the name of this movie is this
even gonna go anywhere it's probably an
indie film and I was just like what the
[__] is this then we drive all the way
out here it's 5 a.m what did it end up
being
I don't know I just remember there being
like a fight a fight and it was it felt
kind of like looking back now it was at
least medium budget because I had like
trailers for people and [__] and there
was like a fight and everything
and um and everyone had their wardrobe
and by the time they're done like
whatever dress shirt or Blazer you had
when you go and pick up your just day
Rate Check it's either you keep the
shirt or they'll write you a check so
good keep the shirt so you can keep the
shirt or they'll give you your like 50
bucks or whatever as an extra so so when
I did when I did ringer
[Music]
the director calls me up and he's like
hey
um do you want to be in the music video
and I was like sure I didn't know
there's a song even I was like for sure
so then I show up same [__] two in the
morning ish
um and then it I I walk into a room and
it's hot as [__] it's like 107 degrees
inside because we're like in this studio
and they have lights on and [__] and
Smoky and it was just me and GloZell you
guys remember GloZell yeah of course
she's freaking green yeah Green
everywhere green oh gee baby and I love
her I've known her forever and I love
her she's awesome person
um so then me and GloZell were asked to
like dance against a wall for like
[__] three hours
like it was ridiculous right you're such
a dancer I'm a dancer so then we're just
like doing this [__] and it's like hot
and like [__] sweating everywhere and
all this [__] and then um and then
they're like okay we're gonna do the
limo thing now and like okay Stephen
GloZell let's go to the limo should I
get into the Lima and into a limousine
and then I'm in there it's Kevin Harden
there it's me
GloZell's in there and then in comes
what's her name from uh Big Bang Theory
the chick who the the white chick the
blonde chick uh is it Amanda something I
didn't watch it I didn't know like the
one that's not blossom yeah but she yeah
but everyone knows her face and she's
famous I don't know her name very famous
person so then she gets in the car and
then everyone's kind of like like her
and like Josh Gad and Kev are like kind
of [__] riffing with each other and
I'll never forget
I'll never forget it's that moment that
you have where you realize you're not in
the group oh no so then I like they're
like bidding with something right and
then somebody else tags in and then I
come in with a little thing and then
nobody says anything oh God and then
you're just like
you just feel like your soul leave your
body and you look down on everything
you're like oh God like we are not in
the group dude is it because they they
shut you off because you're not in their
crowd or just think they don't know if
I'm like some weird extra or some [__]
because because there is that right so
you just don't know and sometimes you
have to defend yourself a little bit
because like they don't want to give you
the olive branch for nothing exactly and
sometimes if you unfortunately because
of the industry if you talk to the wrong
extra you're gonna talk to them for the
rest of your life
that's true yeah so like I I can
understand it now but in the moment I
was just [__] riffing and being a
[__] idiot right just like it was
early in the morning I'm just trying to
be friendly and stuff but then like
looking back it's like oh you just don't
forget [__] like that yeah it is an
ouchy yeah it's a big time oofi yeah you
guys want to see a funny racist thing
yeah you're in a funny racist name me
too send to me too
yeah so this is for like uh Shake It Up
So 2009 and then yeah and then they gave
me lines for this one uh section they
were like oh you're gonna talk to uh
Zendaya and what's her other the other
girl but the new lines were so like kind
of borderline races but it's really
funny let me know if this is racist
oh [__]
do they have shopping
so as the expert so I am complicit come
get me next shark
oh [__] that's hilarious I like how you
guys all airport at the same time I
think that was the most racist part of
that whole thing
foreign